[Música]
buenas indudablemente la época en que
vivimos nos obliga a filosofar un poco
en torno a todo lo que está pasando a
nuestro alrededor
podríamos decir que al ver cambio en el
año 1947 ya nos indicaba que algo podía
pasar a través de su libro la peste
donde podemos ver unidos lo mejor y lo
peor de la humanidad él nos decía que la
expectativa de la enfermedad y la muerte
nos coloca ante las preguntas
fundamentales que solemos evitar o
postergar y muy probablemente eso es lo
que está pasando en este momento donde
no tenemos una certeza clara de qué es
lo que va a ocurrir en su maravilloso
libro saramago del ensayo de la ceguera
no se explica cómo una persona queda
ciega la ve un médico el cual
posteriormente también queda ciego y así
se va expandiendo una epidemia por toda
la ciudad esta epidemia también demostró
que dentro de nosotros existe algo que
no tiene nombre y eso es lo que
realmente somos y ese algo para el que
no hay un nombre
es lo que eventualmente podemos sacar o
bien podemos evitar sacar en una época
de crisis como la actual la doctrina del
shock' más reciente de naomi klein ella
dice que el virus por si mismo es el
shock y que se vende más con el miedo
que incluso con el sexo entonces toda
esta serie de circunstancias en torno al
coronavirus ya esta nueva enfermedad que
desde el 8 de diciembre del año pasado
afecta a la humanidad nos tiene que
poner a reflexionar sobre la relación
que tenemos con nosotros mismos y con el
resto de las personas pero bueno a lo
que vinimos a hablar de que es
cuarentena hace muchos años en el año
1348 la humanidad se vio diezmada por la
peste murieron 120 millones de personas
y como pueden ver en la minilla un
médico de la época se cubría con todo lo
que podía y le colocaba gasas dolorosas
a perfume a ese pico que tiene en su
máscara
evitar que lo que no sabía que era
entrar a su organismo pareciera ser que
lo mismo pasa ahora cuando en ciertas
circunstancias que no necesariamente son
las idóneas utilizamos una mascarilla
para sentirnos protegidos no
necesariamente para que ésta nos proteja
pueden ver ustedes que significa una
cuarentena obligatoria y que puede pasar
en los diferentes escenarios pueden
observar como sin ninguna estrategia de
prevención van a ver personas que nunca
se van a infectar por diferentes razones
otras que van a tener infección y por
supuesto un gran grupo de personas se va
a recuperar estos son escenarios donde
no se hace ninguna estrategia de
prevención y pareciera ser que es a lo
que apuesta nuestro hermano país de
nicaragua si ustedes hacen un
distanciamiento social moderado como el
que acabamos de pasar vamos a tener a
muchas personas sin infección
algunas personas se van a recuperar y
vamos a tener a personas con infección
pero que se van presentando
lo largo del tiempo de una manera que
podríamos decir decir que es ordenada a
eso es lo que llamaríamos aplanar la
curva cuando ya necesitamos un
distanciamiento social exhaustivo la
cantidad de personas sin infección es
más grande con infecciones más pequeño
lo mismo que los recuperados pero ya que
ustedes qué interesante lo que pasa con
la cuarentena obligatoria no
necesariamente es la mejor estrategia
pero si podría ser la cuarentena
obligatoria la que más problemas
sociológicos económicos de violencia
etcétera pueden ocurrir en una sociedad
que está ante algo nuevo algo que sin
lugar a dudas le está ocasionando miedo
y pongámosle rostro a lo que está
pasando les deje esta diapositiva con
dos personas de espalda en un ambiente
oscuro y yo les pido a ustedes que
traten de que esas dos personas vuelvan
a verlos a ustedes y pongan en ese
rostro a su mamá a su papá a sus abuelos
oa una persona querida de esa manera van
más fácilmente porque es necesario
entrar en una eventual cuarentena o en
un distanciamiento social de diferentes
grados que es en este momento lo que
nosotros estamos haciendo en costa rica
por otro lado siempre las situaciones
tienen dos caras una moneda siempre va a
tener dos caras y cada acción va a
generar una reacción y esa reacción
puede ser positiva o puede ser negativa
si ustedes ven la cuarentena desde el
punto de vista el privilegio que ustedes
tienen su quinta en orotina en
guanacaste o en cualquier otro lugar
para ustedes eso va a ser unas
vacaciones sin embargo si ustedes lo ven
desde la pobreza desde la necesidad de
todos los días salir a ganarme
lo que necesito para alimentar a mi
familia van a ver como la perspectiva
cambia de ahí que tenemos que ver todas
las aristas de esta crisis social que
tenemos porque no solamente afecta
parte de la salud
una cosa muy interesante es que de ella
hace poco decía que dirían los filósofos
tradicionales si vivieran en esta época
y friedrich nietzsche posiblemente diría
quedes en casa por más difícil que sea
para usted soportar su propia presencia
enfrentarnos a estar solos en la casa o
máximo con dos o tres personas no salir
tener que convivir todos los días o
conmigo misma o con los demás
plantea un reto no solo sanitario
también sino también filosófico creo que
es un buen momento para meditar estamos
ante un riesgo percibido por un gran
sesgo cognitivo todos los días pasamos
oyendo hablar del cobi 19 y eso por
supuesto que nos va a producir una
angustia que no necesariamente es la que
corresponde a la realidad nos hemos
convertido de ateos a creyentes de anti
vacunas a proba cunas de ones
neoliberales a keynesianos y de
ciudadanos comunes y corrientes a
expertos en todos los campos en que no
diariamente lo somos pero tenemos que
pensar qué papel queremos jugar en la
pandemia
queremos ser héroes o queremos ser
villanos los sueños héroes son
propositivos actúan trabajan los
villanos son los que tratan de
entorpecer todo y nos parece ser que eso
lo hemos visto en diferentes políticos
nacionales y extranjeros como tratan de
meterle ruido al manejo que el
ministerio de salud le está dando a la
pandemia no perdamos la esperanza esto
va a pasar el 80% de las personas se
recuperan sin que necesiten ningún
tratamiento especial y también ya es
hora de que pensemos en el día después
de mañana cuál es la enseñanza en salud
que esto nos va a dejar y cuál es la
enseñanza en la ciudadanía que nosotros
vamos a adquirir a través de esta
experiencia que puede ser traumática
pero podemos sacarle aspectos muy
positivos a la misma muchísimas gracias
por la atención
[Música]